best-selling author John Grisham has
sold more than listen to this boys and
girls okay 300 million copies of his
book ah 300 million
they include classics like the firm and
a time to kill Grisham has had 29
consecutive number-one books on the New
York Times fiction bestseller list his
work has been translated into nearly 50
languages now he is out with his 30th
novel Camino Island it is about a heist
of the original manuscripts of F scott
Fitzgerald's novels and the efforts to
retrieve them John Grisham joins us now
and welcome back always for my pleasure
so here you are yeah you love rare books
hmm so you knew about them had great
affection for them how how did you
create these characters Caleb yeah and
Mercer well I wanted to write a I want
to write a beach book yeah for years my
novels have been criticized as being you
know nothing more than Beach books so I
thought okay I'll show you a beach book
go get them Griffin the ultimate Beach
book there you go that was how I got
started a mystery without lawyers not a
legal thriller but and then I do enjoy
rare books and that's something I want
to write about myself has a theft in a
big time theft starts off with a
big-time theft but but not only that
Charlie the big-time theft is so
detailed it's so detailed with how the
theft is carried out how it's covered on
the news how the how the people decided
on the theft it made me think you know a
lot for a law-abiding citizen on how to
pull off a crime I faked it all is all
fake it's all I got it from Google no I
was no did you really I was really
fascinated by the detail of houses SEP
was pulled off with these rare
manuscripts I have no idea how to steal
manuscripts I've never done it before I
imagine I made it up you know that some
research the manuscripts are really at
Princeton in the Firestone library
that's true that's all true I apologized
to Princeton and my author's note for
for you know for talking about their
manuscripts I don't know why I apologize
it was on the website it's all on
website they have a huge website so why
did you apologize well you know that
this is the type of attention they
probably don't want the fear is you may
inspire someone to try this yeah because
it's a library not a bank not a not a
vault not not a place which is the
reason you say you make it up heavily
all right right somebody that's all
fiction but there was a lot in the book
about you know it's bookstores that you
are now going to do your first book tour
in many years and you're going to
bookstores right because I'm bored
very unusual for you I should go to
bookstores yeah best-selling writers
should go to bookstores to say thanks to
the booksellers and to meet fans sign
autographs on books talk whatever and
I'm gonna do that for the first time in
25 years the other interesting is you
bring up rare books which you have
several of them do you have any f scott
Fitzgerald rare books you do right I
have three of his five I don't have the
Great Gatsby I have I don't have
beautiful no down I have this side
paradise and I kid right now can't look
at the others but they're they're
they're they're pretty rare what kept me
first edition first printing first
praise you got the same thing first it
isn't first printing and it depends on
how how small that first printing is and
how rare the book is for example a
pristine copy of the Great Gatsby had a
small first printing if you can find one
one recently solar was offered for sale
for a quarter of a million dollars yeah
that's that's had the value of some of
these things can I come back to
character so brick cable is on an island
somewhere
yeah we've been florida camino al camino
island right the title of the book did
you model him after somebody do you just
make him up period I've made him up yeah
about Mercer the young woman made her
first and we're gonna make her up here
especially but risk able wears a pigeon
yeah but sometimes you base it on
something to Charlie's point Mercer main
bruise cable wears seersucker suits
yellow in all colors in a boat I'm
thinking I don't know what kind of dude
that is but he's very charismatic
involved in an open loves women loves
women loves to drink and party and but
he's also very serious book seller yes
that's a great bookstore he makes a lot
of money with rare books and he's
unknown to most folks he dabbles in
stolen rare books yes that's where he
makes a lot of money and that's how he
gets involved in this plot but the whole
time I'm reading I think I wonder if
John really feels this way because in
the book they say writers fall into two
camps those who know the ending before
it begins and the other who well most
writers will tell you they have no idea
when they start yeah they create a great
character
and that character takes over the action
and they follow that character wherever
he or she wants to go that's total [ __ ]
where do you fall oh okay yeah you have
to plot plotting takes at work you have
to carefully plot and outline your story
before you start if you especially if
you're writing mysteries or suspense or
thriller is where the plots can get very
intricate you take it takes a lot of
work I mean I spend a lot of time
outlining before I write the first word
and you do writing tips and this is what
I really like don't write a prologue I
love that I got that from male more
Leonard
none of these are original I hate
prologues because they're kind of
gimmicks just suck you in these writing
tips you shared them with the New York
Times and I think they're great as y'all
Gail number one you wrote do write a
page every day if you're yes when you
start your first novel you hopefully
have a job doing something else so you
have to carve out some time but until
you're doing one page a day every day
nothing's going to happen and that saved
me 30 years ago with the time to kill
because I would I had to had learned
that lesson the hard way I would put it
down and nothing would happen for two
weeks I made myself write least a page a
day yeah and you say write it at the
same time and place every day to remind
me of the thing about routine remember
the f ing routine Scott Turow wrote
presumed innocent on the train the one
to work every morning in Chicago he had
but he had a spot he wrote the great
novel 30 years ago his first big book on
the train but don't keep with the so
don't keep with the Souris within
reaching distance do not because there
are three types of words you said well
there are three types of words we all
know your words we should know in words
nobody what do you know don't use the
third category don't know buddy know
much of the plot comes after you get
involved in writing after you put pen to
paper and you're in Chapter four and you
realize I'll think something that you're
going to put in rule number two yes
don't write the first word until you
know the last scene yeah outline but in
between things happen because we are
acting you can't you can't outline 400
pages right and you don't want to
because but the surprises are fun right
are the characters that pop up for no
reason the characters go over the
characters you kill off that's always
alright but you can't you can't predict
what's going to happen but you better
know your last scene and you better know
where you're going I knew the last thing
of this book the flywheel challenge you
said every writer has a mean streak of
envy this is what Mercer says
do you think every writer has a mean
streak of envy you talking about myself
no in Mercer has struggling okay he's
really she's had writer's block for
seven years she can't finish your novel
she's she's struggling so she's got some
baggage okay it's a funny I'm not
envious yeah I think I have read every
single one of your books
the wit the last ones to the Whistler
rogue lawyer gray mountain Sycamore row
they were all really excellent food so
great to as we begin the summer time
thank you
yeah yeah hey I'm her startin where's my
Shake Shack when I got will patient you
to go to Shake Shack go get a burger yet
so pay for it yes we'll give a little
table guys you'll see them pay for
charlie will we do it big into that tree
a John Grisham would you get an offer
take it in smile let's pass the Hat for
John Grisham's you talk about torture
you bring a basketball number one they
are both Carolina Tar Heel it's past
half sort out there yeah I thank you oh
he needs it needs a donation we're
outside 300 300 only a deck sold yeah we
can get your bird who's counting who's
counting those books er I want to meet
that person we are meet wife oh yeah
Camino Island on the sail now